you're joining us live here in turkey
with our special coverage of the second
round of turkia's presidential election
let's bring you up to speed with where
we're at right now well the vote
counting has begun we're at so far a
fifth of the votes counted according to
anadolo news agency they're trying to
figure out and I'm if you see me
glancing down often trying to figure out
what are the initial results and whether
we're allowed to go with it or waiting
for the all clear on that one well we've
got a number of correspondents covering
this story across turkia we've got
Hashem alabara he's at the jeophe
headquarters the headquarters of the
opposition party in Ankara we've got
Cinema Live for us from Istanbul but
first let's start with rasool Sardar he
joins us from the presidential Palace in
Ankara they must be on a knife's edge
there waiting for an indication of where
this is going rasul
absolutely Sammy so now we are in front
of the presidential Palace in Ankara and
the other the preparations are on the
way so president erdogan within hours
he's expected to arrive to Ankara and
come to the presidential Palace and also
From A Balcony to deliver a speech to
his uh supporters so that is quite
unusual because president erdogan
usually his traditional balcony speech
will happen and the art parties uh the
headquarters in Ankara but this time he
preferred to speak to address his
supporters from the presidential Palace
so according to some sources from the
government they say that so far about 30
percent of the Woods have been counted
they're saying they are leading however
in any way what is clear is that it is
enough as of now still a neck and neck
race and it has it has been in the last
two weeks during the presidential
campaign for the second round of the
election however for now many people
millions in Turkey maybe across the
world are very much closely watching
this election and very curious to see
what's going to be the result who is
going to win and who is going to lose
however here there is a specific group
that is definitely much more carefully
meticulously carefully watching this
elections and they are the millions of
refugees in Turkey
many consider this election to be
turkey's most significant in its recent
history
erdogan voted in Istanbul where he began
his political career
he has reshaped the nation in the last
two decades
his supporters believe he has made it
more powerful Emperor's Paris
I want erdogan to win for the sake of
stability for this country
stability and continuity have been the
message throughout erdogan's election
campaign
but after more than two decades in power
he now faces his most difficult
challenge
six opposition parties have joined
forces for this presidential runoff with
opposition leader Kamal conestarolo
chosen as their unified candidate
he was second in the first round on May
14th
as he came to Cassie's worth in Ankara
he was welcomed by his supporters
they are grown more confident that he
will be turkey as next president
the whole nation wants change because
our country wants its rights Justice and
rule of law
neither president erdogan nor the
opposition leader kalistaro consecuted
enough Wars to win in the first round it
was the high Wars for nationalist
parties that forced the election to the
second round the rise of the Nationalist
parties was the main surprise of the
first round that has forced the
presidential candidates to reconsider
their election strategy to appeal to the
Nationalist Awards in the runoff
the opposition leader kalistaro has
focused his second round campaign on
anti-refugee sentiments promising to
send home millions of Syrian Afghan and
Pakistani refugees syrians will go as
one of the main slogans written on
billboards
as a result the leader of the ultra
nationalist Victory party amid USDA has
announced his support for kalistarovo
but
synonymous presidential candidate who
came third in the first round has
decided to support president erdogan in
the runoff
the preliminary results will be
announced hours after Water cast their
ballots
but this election is closely washed
especially by millions of refugees
facing fear and uncertainty
Al Jazeera Ankara
and Russell your package touched upon
there the issue of the Nationalist vote
and these are the moments the coming
moments where we find out just how
successful or otherwise the pivot
towards the national vote has been right
absolutely Sammy it was the biggest
surprise of the first round seeing the
rise of the Nationals parties in Turkey
so the conservatives in this country
were holding their ground however there
was a huge rise of the Nationalist
parties and that's why right after the
first round we have seen a race started
to appeal the the Nationalist Wars and
so the Kamal he has changed his rhetoric
his mild-mannered rhetoric and tried to
appeal the Nationalist Wars by
particularly focusing on the
anti-refugee sentiments and promising to
send millions of the refugees back and
so on and so as a result he got the
support of the ultra nationalist parties
with the support of ultra nationalist
party the victory party but erdogan also
has done quite a lot to appeal the
others like sinan organ and so on so but
one thing is is interesting here Sammy
So this Ultra nationalist parties are
quite new parties and we do not know how
is going to be they Waters reaction in
the second round they because their
their loyalties to their leaders have
never been tested before that's why it's
quite difficult to predict how they are
going to react but these questions are
going to be answered within hours as now
more than 30 percent of the wars are
already counted
all right good stuff there from rasool
sarda thanks so much for that let's
bring you up to speed as Russell
mentioned there around I'm just double
checking the number here according to
another dollar news agency we're getting
close to a third of the vote having been
counted we still are awaiting the all
clear though from the high Election
Commission to start getting into some
numbers the good news is we understand
they're getting ready to make an
announcement so hopefully that will come
pretty soon well let's now go over to
Hashem alabara he's live for us at the
jehepe headquarters the headquarters of
the opposition party in Ankara and
Hashem tell us a little bit about the
mood there as we await these crucial
numbers to come in
bring you up to date with the latest as
far as the opposition is concerned there
was a pressure by the spokesperson of
the CHP a while ago and this is what I
have to say he said basically that the
they have called all their
representatives
in all the polling stations to be very
careful and to ensure that there are no
regarded irregularities whatsoever we
have to remind our viewers that during
the first round of the election the
opposition said that there were many
irregularities and filed many objections
to the high election committee the Y
Escape now
there are some indications that we'll
have to look at Sami to that would give
us some indications about what we should
be expecting tonight I've been talking
to many members of the opposition
basically they say
the biggest hope tonight is to see the
voter turnout exceeding 89 percent
higher than the first round for them
that could be a good sign that they
might have more voices they do vote they
do understand that this is going to be a
complex task ahead for them that the for
them to expand the electoral map they
will have to go to different uh
votes from different parts of the
country
a lower vote turnout is going to be
definitely bad news for the opposition
if it happens tonight
and Hashem just to put this into
perspective there is a lot at stake here
for the opposition a big push made a lot
of things at stake for kalist the leader
of that Alliance and a lot at stake for
the table of six
that Alliance that brought together six
parties right these are the make or
break moments for them now
indeed it is the most important
political fight for Kamal kilisticex 74
year old politician and Economist to win
this election it became somehow his
motto his reson data and he said I'm
determined to defeat president
promising people
to restore the parliamentary system to
fix the economy and to bring more
political freedoms to the country to do
that
he built this Alliance of six political
parties which were always
divided over a wide range of issues but
this time they decided to set aside
those differences and to move forward
just to remind our viewers in March a
key partner of Kelly
said that she's not really confident
they can win this election with kamales
as the main candidate
in the election she only stayed in the
Coalition when she got some concessions
from
about including some of his top aides
particularly at monsoriavash and eklam
Emmanuel as vice presidential candidate
what happens tonight this is going to be
an extremely delicate moment a a loss by
the opposition
will be a complete reset for the
opposition Alliance and also the future
of the opposition candidate
but for the time being the spokesperson
said they're confident they're going to
win this election he also said that we
are promising that our win will Usher in
a new spring for the people of turkey
now we'll have to wait and see whether
they were able to win the hearts and
Minds of the undecided voters but more
importantly whether they were able to
convince the ultra nationalists who were
the biggest surprise in this election
that it was about time for a change in
Turkey so all these issues will continue
to be at stake until we get a final
result about what was the choice of the
Turkish people tonight Sammy
and hopefully that final result coming
in soon thanks so much there let's take
this to cinema she's in Istanbul and
soon bring us up to speed with how this
is unraveling across social media across
the media
well Sami the higher election board
hasn't announced anything yet about
lifting the election Bannon media
however TV outlets and online platforms
have already is began announcing the
results the so far result let me say on
their platforms and it seems that the
turnout is still high but the turnout in
the runoff might be left a few points
below the first round which was around
90 percent this is what we are all
expecting right now on the other hand
for now since they are opening the
ballot boxes in the small populated
cities they are not giving us a clear
idea but the ruling up party side seems
to be confident about winning this
election however when you look look at
the streets Sami this is what I have
been explaining in our bulletin so far
there isn't any excitement yes Turkish
people always take the polls seriously
they go to the polling stations I
remember from my childhood people used
to wear their best uh tuxedos best suits
when they when they used to go to the
pools they take it seriously but uh the
the excitement is not as it used to be
this is what we feel and I'm hearing
from my sources in the Eastern region
that in the Kurdish dominated areas the
turnover going to the ballots the
appetite by the Kurds for the runoff
might be left a little bit again lower
than the first round of course we will
see the results shortly as this was only
a presidential race between two
candidates that's why the voting lasted
it's worked it flows much properly
compared to the first round to uh two
weeks ago until then we have no idea but
of course the results always may have
surprises but one thing is clear despite
the turnout is still very high compared
to many other countries in the world
this will be below the first rounds to
uh turn out Sammy
foreign
as we are waiting I'm hearing that the
media ban is lifted now trying to see if
we can get some numbers in but do tell
me if you've got any indication where
you are our electrical systems a little
soggy with rain right now as we get them
sorted out tell me if you've got any
indication of those first results
okay since the band is lifted let's go
with some figures they turn the turnout
seems to be around 84 Sami which is
lower than the first round as I said and
so far at least 20 percent of the ballot
boxes have been open and according to
the initial results president erdogan is
ahead of his rival Kamal college terolo
but of course it depends on where you
begin to open the ballot boxes the
smaller cities with smaller populations
it's easy to count the warts out there
unless the votes in big cities like
Istanbul Ankara Izmir Antalya and until
these words are counted we don't have
any uh proper result and when the
ballots uh the polls are being opened at
the beginning the the ratios are much
higher than it is expected but many
sense that President erdogan will be
lucky in the runoff as well this is the
situation in terms of figures right now
Sami
all right thanks so much
there I'm gonna now be able to bring you
the first figures which are coming in
again
these are initial not official these are
initial results being reported by
anadolo news agency with 42 of the vote
these are not final results by any
stretch of the imagination but so far
again we have a picture of urduan the
president in the lead with
57.09 percent of the vote command
with
42.9 of the vote
once again these are not official
results they are not final results these
are the results coming in from anadolo
news agency and they are reflecting 42
of the vote having been counted so
I guess this is the time to bring in our
guests and try and unwrap this and see
what it means we're delighted to have
with us braving the rain and the wind
which is blowing our stuff away here Ali
good to have you back with us Ali
chagrolo from Koch University so here we
go 57 for type erdogan 42 so far for
not the final results only 42 can we
build too much into it at this at this
point I wouldn't
um because early results
I respect that in you thank you but the
earliest results that we received from
social media indicated a slight lead by
karishtarovo now we with a larger
percentage of uh votes the pictures
changing from one counted a picture is
changing I expect this margin to narrow
as we go along but the last time we had
this kind of margin it really stops at
14 49.5 percent
I mean you're right the margin did close
but the pattern stays for most of the
night I think it's fair to say I'm
thinking back to that first day the
pattern of who's ahead and who's
trailing did not just for a big chunk of
the knife at least I think it's safe to
say it didn't change can we make that
assumption or again should we be more
cautious Allah Ali depending on what you
want to observe at the end of the day
the facts we don't we don't want we
don't want to get into speculators such
an important election that people have
difficult time believing even in the
truth itself right so let's wait that's
my suggestion okay
that let me try and look at it from
another perspective though I'm not going
to try and pull you into guessing
numbers no there used to be a day I'm
sure you remember in this country when
results would come in earlier from the
East I see
that has changed now that has changed so
can we does can we look at it it's not
like this does it give us any indication
to where fire might be leading in or
again should we no there to my knowledge
uh that kind of pattern cannot be
established for this new system because
in the past the polls opened earlier and
closed earlier in the East now
all over the country it's the same time
period for voting and
smaller
constituencies are more likely to
actually do the counting more quickly
and and send in the results that's the
only assumption we can make about these
most likely these come from smaller
constituencies where count is easier all
right I'm gonna flip around my little
screen here so you can see what I'm
looking at this is the map of so far
where the results are coming in and
who's leading where it didn't change
that was what I was going to ask you
doesn't look like there's so many
surprises so far the the heartland of
turkey it seems that's where erdogan is
doing well so far just just to
underscore it's only 42 of the vote
coming well that geography the heartland
of here and has a larger number of seats
but in this election seed numbers really
doesn't count what matters is where the
waters are and the waters are in the red
areas that we see where commissioner is
winning
mostly Western and Coastal provinces
Istanbul is is there Ismail is there
an Ankara in the Heartland is also where
Krishna roll is leading and so three
large
metropolitan areas is where most waters
are almost almost 40 percent of turkey
if I remember correctly is living in
those three cities right and that's
where christero is getting its words and
this election is different so you get
one more vote than your competitor you
win the election all right that's a
beautiful point for us to segue offers
so thank you so much thank you for
coming and explaining that to us let me
update you first on what we're seeing so
far with the results before we segue off
of Ali's final point there well we're
now at almost half of all votes have
been counted 49 of votes have been
counted and so far here is the result
has more percent of the votes so far
56.3 percent of the vote
with Kamal kalashtalu at 43 percent
of the vote so far so once again type
erdogan we can see a similar pattern so
far emerging of what we saw on the first
night where Thai bordwan was ahead he's
ahead so far in this stage but that
margin of his how much he's ahead by
this trunk ever so slightly but it's
still a significant lead for him so far
we're going to have to keep an eye on
this obviously it's still early days or
early hours we're only halfway through
the vote counting and as Ali said we've
got to keep an eye on some of the key
areas in this vote well on Alexa O'Brien
has been looking at how some of those
clear key areas played out in the first
round of voting in this package
biggest cities and in the election
earlier this month all the provinces
around those cities here in red voted
for the opposition candidate Kamal
Khalid that's a shift away from Rich of
type erdogan who took both Ankara and
Istanbul in 2018. but this year he lost
those provinces by about one or two
percentage points and there was a much
wider margin in Izmir however it
traditionally votes for the opposition
erdogan didwin as expected in the
central conservative Heartland here in
yellow his party's support base but with
fewer votes compared to 2018 he also won
an eight of the 11 provinces badly
affected by those earthquakes in
February analysts suggests that's
because of the governing party's promise
to rebuild the devastated cities further
south east is where most of the Kurdish
population is concentrated the main
pro-kurdish party under the green left
Banner through its support behind
kilichterolu and Kurdish voters followed
suit
then there's Western Europe where the
vast majority of the Turkish diaspora
lives and its 3.4 million registered
voters about 55 percent of those cast
ballots in the runoff vote that's even
more than in the May 14 election when 57
of them voted for Erawan and the
candidate who finished third in the
first round senen Owen won about five
percent of votes overall he has endorsed
Erawan to win
but it's unclear how Owen's supporters
will vote in the runoff and what that
will mean for these two men and their
political ambitions
all right so unclear how they're going
to vote but we are getting some
indications of how things have been
going so far in this photo let me bring
you up to speed with the election
results as reported by anadolo news
agency and I have to underscore these
are not the final results we're at
almost half of votes counted 49 of votes
counted
erdogan ahead so far with 56 percent of
the votes in second place obviously
Kamal kalash.olu
quite behind so far at
43.64 of the votes let's analyze things
further we have Cedar damera joining us
here it's windy it's cold thanks for
coming said oh you've been a real
Soldier about this your political uh
professor of political science at usherk
University in Istanbul now it's just
jumped as I was turning around to talk
to you and we've got
55 of votes counted the lead still for
tiberduan but it's gone down a bit he's
now at 55 of the vote
verses 44 for kamalu now it's still
quite a sizable gap between the two
candidates is that significant at this
stage
well the Gap is
um no actually or lower than expected
considering it's an adult agency and
there's also other sources that
um that give more like a knife edge
results right so I would say that this
is
a more optimistic scenario for the
opposition
because many were fearing that in the
opposition that erdogan would win with a
landslide Victory but it so far do these
numbers I mean suggest to you that that
is not going to happen there won't be a
landslide right because it looks like
the Gap can be closed in the upcoming
hours that's what we saw in the previous
round that we saw in 2018 elections
typically we see another agency starting
incumbent votes where they're much
higher
rate and the margin closer is over the
next hours so we may expect a similar
change and a closing of the Gap it's not
a gap that cannot be closed in the
upcoming hours tell us now how soon we
should expect them to get through the
vote counting in the in the first round
it it dragged on didn't it especially
when it came to the last five or two
percent that really dragged on are we
going to see a repeat of that scenario
or things going to be a lot quicker and
smoother now I was saying things would
be much faster much quicker now that
it's just the presidential election and
just that it's just two candidates now
so we may expect a more definite result
in a much shorter period of time all
right now I'm going to ask you if you're
comfortable to to look at these numbers
do they tell us anything about the
Nationalist camp or is it still too
early to say who won over the
nationalists well I would say the
Nationalist Camp clearly did not just
unanimously support our Dawn otherwise
you would see our Dawn much more ahead
so I would say
many of the Nationalist voters did
actually go and vote for kalistarolo
some of them did go vote for Ardon but
they did split we know that
to know more we need to wait a couple
more hours seriously okay let me ask you
another question again looking at these
initial results and looking at the
spread
I'm not sure if you saw moments ago
we had this map and from the projections
by an adult or news agency it wasn't a
huge surprise the main areas showing
support so far so far the election the
votes are not all counted but they were
in the Heartland areas of turkey showing
support for type of urduan does that
tell us anything about the Kurdish Vote
or is it still too early I think we need
to wait a couple more hours
to see what Kurdish Waters decided
still too soon for that to reach a
conclusion
all right well there's plenty of more
hours to come so I'm gonna let you go in
and warm up thank you so much Sarah no
problem all right let's bring you up to
speed with where we are now then 55 of
the votes have been counted eruduan is
ahead with 55.8 percent of the vote so
far
allo is behind him with 54.2 of the
votes this is according to annadulla
news agency who have to underscore these
are not final these are not official
results
we'll be here monitoring this as it
comes in